talking about you're sucking off Dana
you know like I'm just I'm just let's
say this you had to go you had to gay
out or whatever with one good fighter in
the UFC and it can be any weight class
like I mean you're talking about
physically somebody no it can be just a
date it could be but there's some
kissing at the end if you and don't pick
a little weight class either no offense
to any of those guys they're Warriors
but pick something [__] don't be a
pervert you know who's it going to be oh
[__] cuz there's some handsome guys out
there yeah there's some good looking U
SE Fighters oh man am I doing the
[__] I'm doing the [__] right dude
what I just told you you can't there's
no guarantee not going to see France
ganu if I'm not doing the one doing the
[__] look just I'm trying to die here
[__] here you go hottest UFC
fighters of 2020 I better be on that
[__] you better scroll down
we're about to find out who's number one
scoll a [__] Paulo Costa is number one
go back up let's start with number
one why don't we who's number two you
got discipl this is why you yell at you
got a discipline my Jamie bro
[__] have no discipline it's
only while we went to number seven
before we even started counting that's
that's how these people are if you yeah
we got Pao Costa what do you think one
to 10 where would you take
him I
mean beautiful beautiful guy I mean he's
a good like
Brazilian dude I don't know if he's been
waxed or not I'm just saying that he
seems like he's a handsome guy I mean I
would think that he would be um I think
that he seems a little bit more like I
think he would take it for sure you know
I mean as like as his Persona I think
that like if cas's if there's going to
be some [__] he's gonna be the one
bent over the the shower you know it's
gonna cost her for saying that dude I
think dude I don't know you're probably
gonna have to fight that guy oh I none
of this get in well but how does this so
who but who would you take honestly you
got to take one guy on a nice nice night
out and it's an Anno in the UFC no why
don't we rephrase that now we don't want
to [__] because I mean come on now well
yeah I didn't say you're the one who
said it I'm not a gay but um I would do
let me let's say who do I who do I
respect in the UFC who do I admire in
the UFC somebody I
respect and it can be a nice dinner and
the only thing you have to do at the end
say something real nice to
him long hug too but the the hug also
are you a hugger dude I don't hug men I
don't hug men the hug can be from the
back that's all I'm saying I don't hug
men the hug can be from the
back a [__] a dude yeah [__] this
list I'm now Chandler's hands too porier
is handsome what about sah gain got o i
to get a little step stool to hug him
but maybe no he's French too he's a nice
guy oh Alo I don't know about aljo
dude you know good guy he's a good guy
though good Evan Williams what about
him Jon Jones no no yeah Jon Jones ain't
a good looking dude I don't know about
that I just don't know I don't want to I
wouldn't go on a date with him no Jon
Jones ain't the one
dude oh Thiago Moises huh [__] this list
D I'm not on this list [__] this list
but in the future you'll be on this list
man I doubt it dude really I doubt it
man you could be a model for something I
mean I was say you put me at 170 to Su
bro I'm [__] getting all monster
jacked oh dude you could be a model for
something probably go one what you think
you'd Model Auto Parts look at that guy
that's me oh my god
dude